hello and welcome to another episode of
top 5 Skyrim mods of the week I'm on the
right I'm on the right which means I'm
in charge and on the Left I have Lucy
James welcome Lucy James Lucy why don't
you explain to us why why is this why is
why is why is why are you here why is I
killed kam with knives assorted Scottish
blood everyone's [__] for go on it was
like iron brew yeah um I killed kam
racist and you kind of took his seat I
did and I've taken you so I'm moving up
the chain of succession fine it is the
game of games spot of throne games oh
that was good that was good also we
hired you yeah also that happened yeah
Lucy works for us now uh Lucy you are
technically guesting on the show that
you know yeah we're gonna mix it up a
little bit so what I have allowed you to
do is pick the theme of today's mods
what have you gone poor so I wanted to
pick a game franchise that I know mmm uh
stupidly well stupidly well good um and
there weren't that many Bioshock mods so
could not go for that so much yes hollow
notes would say yes so we went for mass
effects mass effect mods right on all
right well let's crack on with mod
number one
and welcome to mod number one Lucien
also welcome to sunny sunny glorious
pretty white row it's a lovely day it's
one of our favorite places to start and
what we're looking for the skyrim shrink
and growth rays now do you know
whereabouts they might be I've heard
they're just outside up just outside the
blacksmith here right on I'm gonna say
though these take shrink-ray absolutely
take growth ray Lucy I'm gonna let you
govern this where am I going first ah
what what suffers the shrinking or the
groaning I don't know which is which
it's gonna be a mystery uh go up to the
Companions are here aren't they the
Companions are here I think I think they
need to be the first to fall which one
we want to win ah righty or lefty Oh
lefty lefty okay lefty get big I mean
small haha oh my god you tiny little
thing you can't hurt me you're the size
of a button alright
that definitely means that we need to
ambiguous one yeah go wow what happened
sorry what happens if I shrink afire you
Oh super speed is what happens he ducks
can't can i double shrink him stop stop
moving Oh No hold still
come back here
haha again is it tiny thing you made a
borrower oh my god
I made a borrower for a borrower get
smaller smaller still Oh what's a cow
that is how that's our favorite cow
hold still damn it I want a tiny state
to concentrate the flavor oh he's
adorable was he gone quiet it's no pulse
Tony cow missed missed again ha ha and
horses in case they make for speedy
getaways all right uh this one quick
Mountain mountain we can't afford to
lose him back come back you tiny bastard
come on ha ha come on sprint you'll
never catch me you'll never catch me now
what the boo it's like a like a kid he's
riding on the back of a dog jump jump I
said jump I'm on I'm on what the boom
get away I'm out of here
you'll never catch me oh god I'm off
I've lost him in the tall grass that's
how I found him again jump
ride ride I think I think I'm maybe
squash this poor pony into the ground
maybe we should grow him stop panicking
get back you I'm on Oh call me Kevin
city conqueror for the neverending story
oh dear oh dear
infinity as soon as he got the best of
me oh you win again gravity okay well
that was chaos and I think it's probably
time for what number two we can finally
crack into your mass effect mods so Lucy
what's the first Mass Effect mod so the
first one is Mass Effect followers which
is made by Val ma so we are here at the
drunken Huntsman in Whiterun and gonna
pick up a couple guys to take on with us
hopefully we are on the Citadel so who
might we be looking for
oh is it perhaps this guy no I'm going
with tally saw interesting
she's voice-acted yeah how what are you
doing pretty great well could make it
better he'll have you we in love in this
fast I won't let you down do I let me
down
Oh tally you magic a woman and he trains
and things with you to have more pockets
than you'd think
oh I'm so in love with you right now oh
wow let's get let's give her treats I
think I know what I'm gonna give her
yeah one shrink-ray that's yours now you
look after it use it but who else is
this guy need me for something it's
wrong ship it's my love will you join me
who needs their ass kicked
now everyone in Skyrim we could be
friends forget about the collectors
weapons ready that better because I
think this crabs gonna screw me up words
thank you for that Sally Sally she did
it do it again do it again
this time - yep that's amazing she's
pretty effective she's written can we
just have her own apartment all the time
we can they're mercenaries tele eclipse
fight them I'm gonna fight them take
that oh come on Garris
wanna swing Garris when the one grocery
in the crap out of them oh he can't it
doesn't work then oh god he is getting
better Daenerys I will crush them with
my fingers I'm gonna smash their
mercenaries Chapter six
yeah all gasp it's all you come on come
on finish him slowly but surely there we
go there we go
oh you one more hit oh my god yes Gareth
you mighty oh nice and another one he's
found spares
so aside from tally and Gareth there's
still one last thing that we can get as
well I just found this spell tome summon
Harbinger oh yes okay
I think I summon in place oh that's
awesome
that is definitely Oh what so he's my
harbinger does that mean he he'll fight
for me yeah
tally oh ho ho I need you to do
something fight him him
there we go Oh God
he's way more powerful than shear his
stick harbinger please there we go
results so awesome and that is how you
win I believe thank you Harbinger oh
that's a but that's the butt out of the
way of the butt oh look at him I think
he's winning time for mod number three
now tally likes to uh repair things
doesn't she yes yes in fact without herb
basically the Normandy probably wouldn't
fly am I correct
well so since we have her here I wonder
what's happened to the Normandy what is
more number three
well the Normandy there's been a there's
been a little teensy snafus with it oh
yeah the next mod is the Normandy crash
site by lk1 uh whoops indeed because um
well Oh God what's happened
Sally sorry we need you the world of our
ancestors our bodies carried the seeds
that spread the desert grass okay that
thing that's very profound this is your
job this was your only job tally bring
your tools so so let's have a look okay
the Normandy so this is the Normandy one
hop on hop on
no it's it's an or D 2 psi 2 is the
Cerberus 1 and yet it's got the Alliance
oh god that's nerdy I don't know about
you but I walked around the Normandie a
couple of times yeah and I remember the
start to finish run from the Normandy
dump Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim longer than
that
yeah I agree so this is a very condensed
version of the Normandy I think oh
there's Talia she was getting in there
she was getting she she'd gone in for
repairs how's it looking Tali will she
fly ok and while we're here I think it's
probably time for mod number 4 which we
can find just over here excuse me
friends oh look there's a spy otic chest
and what is the name of modern number 4
it is a Mass Effect biotic spell in
Skyrim by all 0 so looks like we've got
some light reading to do we've got a lot
of reading to do we've basically got
every one of the biotic spells from Mass
Effect as a usable spell in Skyrim so
let's take them all let's uh let's maybe
get the hell out of here because we I
think we pissed off a couple of people
let's go lift let's go this okay
oh and up he goes that's exactly right
oh very effective hold on hold on tally
I got this ring ah ah I'm slowly
levitating I got it
that's alright well how much should i do
on tally as well oh dear got it it
doesn't pick and choose next Nova okay
Nova was pretty
I think ya know 15 years
pretty effective we should be good all
right
reve reve just sorta yeah Oh brutal yeah
I feel bad except that that was cool as
it's always slowly slowly killing them
we've got shot away oh it does not
discriminate sorry ah yep that
definitely didn't discriminate
singularity that should make him float I
guess
oh no he brings him to me unless it's
made you a singularity yeah oh that's
funny
oh it's amazing come back here come to
me uh bang fan again see still alive ah
now he's dead he finally died hold still
oh that's too bad
not again while I throw you hey okay
that's cool get this guy believe I can
now change the weapon yeah to do what my
bidding is as well so I make that
shockwave weapon yeah which is
technically a shout yep
can't argue with that she went flying
okay there's definitely results lift
weapon let's see this to it sing go okay
so I think that's it applied
haha just it disarms them and leaves
their weapons in the air I think a woman
give-give that's better than what the
actual biotic spell does me and they
leveled up the biotics in this yeah so
where are we now Lucy we've travelled
across the map to either step I was dead
got it sunny what a day
lovely what is this this was definitely
not here and I was dead before that is a
new development apartments available
here within yeah two bedrooms
reasonable prices they look lovely
frankly I want the one at the top
because I want to be the yawl and that
should be what we can do in this model
because this is the user-mode voted mod
the one that we haven't done for the
last two weeks this has become the Isle
of Ivor stead so something that this mod
has said is that it is largely quest
based so I think we do have our work cut
out for us okay this is not encouraging
people seem to already be dead alright
so first things first we need to come
and find I believe this guy go do it all
ears you're all is now you're all
moustache haven't you seen yourself son
well there's been a huge avalanche here
in the city so we need to go and find
the y'all make sure he's all right I
have a feeling he's not going to be
oh well that's not a good start Oh
whenever I think of avalanches I always
think of the accompanying werewolves are
you naturally natural yeah oh dear
rescue the y'all y'all's dead we found
you y'all bro he's kind of dead
something he dead it's gonna be good for
the people and Iver stead to have you
around it will elevate their morale I
would argue that he never asked for this
I am the law I can't do it Ivan I am
there we go I have a terribly high
feminine voice alright well let's get on
out of here I just hope that onto the
spikes heavens who put those there
okay so we have done so many quests now
the people of Iris Ted are warmed by
your generosity swarms is warm deaths
because of the call the sad death I love
this script hook nurse you widows we can
be husband has died look look the
clothes we saved everyone look at our
bear pelts have made them all warm
so penny there's 400 lines of bespoke
dialogue in this which is kind of cool
like they the guys gone to a lot of
effort to make this mod
sweet and I think he's succeeded what
did you want may I help you talk to me
like yes have you been working hard for
either said I also have to pay my men
for their hard obviously in the spinal
injuries don't worry nothing too bad
cuts scrapes broke legs - nothing - Orin
anyway it should cost 8,000 in court do
you have that amount currently available
I believe I do
- Dragonborn Rifton announcement Rifton
announcement dragon boy we're aware of
the great achievements as well as
sacrifices you have done in the name of
Ivor stead a recognition of your work
will pay him out of 2000 go I just paid
eight thousand in gold I am NOT no
absolutely not
okay I yell a lawgiver so they're good
new enemy type in this the red skulls
earlier we had to collect 30 of their
craniums yeah actual craniums yep fart
No
all right red skull's thought he knows
he knows this land too well ah the
payment as agreed is fifty thousand in
gold oh god I've got a real bad feeling
bravery consists in collecting 100
Kremlin debts and to bring them to me
with the gold what does she plan to do
with 100 craniums oh that was exhausting
but I think we've got our 100 cranium
titles of nobility yes yes this is this
is awesome
Vince now you're one step away from
becoming a yarol you have killed a
hundred savages and I'm exhausted
according to the spy the wizard has a
powerful stick ah oh great can I do for
my friend
retrieve the stick you must find the
stick
there we go wizard it's not carrying a
stick yeah that's right clapping way
over the line yeah I do gnomes with
great joy in my heart and on behalf of
the people of Iver stead that I declared
you the yarl of Iver stead yes don't
live the yaro so I guess we should
probably just take a look at what we
what we own display halt yeah all my
greatest kills um I guess I killed and
stuffed one of the Greybeards this is a
place fit for a fit forgot we got a door
hot tub the hot tub here's what to brew
and we get yeah I thought I just Otto
nude up yeah you did after a hard day's
worth of fetch quests of insane fetch
quest Kevin you have earned this 100
craniums later 130 craniums later well
done Kevin you are y'all I thought maybe
you could use some company tonight
Don yeah you best not these chickens
need need to be bigger
oh god honey
I didn't mean to get you but it's okay
somebody fight for me defend me and
we're uh-oh I hope Dolly's alright
she'll be fine she is strong she was a
strong one yes even better than Garris
Oh Kevin's he looks he's lonely
Oh oh dear oh god he's still falling
still falling still falling okay now
he's fine now
hey that one that went well
I think that went well yep where are we
that was exhausting
yeah well thank you thank you for
joining me on their huge adventure
becoming a yell of Ivor stead is so hard
how like it takes forever as well I
didn't I didn't think that we'd that
much to it Game of Thrones makes it look
so quick no it takes forever so the guy
said that was a basic eight hour mod and
then once you get to where we were then
it can kind of go on indefinitely so we
did Scott good good well we kind of
skipped ahead keep your prisoners happy
make some taxes get food make sure ones
close oh my god all right well B&E ah
was hard work that was for you you voted
for that mod so thanks for that so I
think I'm gonna be a little more
cautious on the more to be put up for
vote but before we get to the mod vote
bit we've got some feedback from last
week yes okay could you please read the
first bit of feedback I love this I took
it a little letter so dear cam and Seb
as a fellow Skyrim er Skyrim Asst
okay yeah that is better yes I think I
should be the one to tell you this you
see although I and the many Skyrim ists
around the world love your show and all
that kevin vanden or does there is one
bone I must pick with you okay while why
must you so slaughter all of those
chickens Oh murder is one thing but you
good sirs are committing mass genocide
of Skyrim chickens I feel like you
should stop calling your show the clock
er cost the clock ecause every week I
see you slaughter hundreds of chickens
but none of them are donated to the
hungry and
of Skyrim if you're gonna kill that many
chickens you should at least put their
bodies to a charitable use that's fair
enough
yeah think of all the hungry and
orphaned children in Riften whose lives
could be made better with chicken
tenders or chicken nuggets made from the
aftermath of the Kevin Van nord clucker
cost wouldn't that also be a cool band
name
either that or Kevin Van Nord and his
chicken van nuggets I'll let you be the
judge
clock Philly Milton pickles I'm Milton
pickle Simon pickle Simon PS hail smart
Wow that is probably the most thorough
and bizarre bit of feedback we've ever
had well Milton pickles I'm er thanks
firstly that was that was a great
message secondly I'd like to put it to
you that what we do is we stand in the
middle of the chickens and detonate them
out in all directions meaning that
precooked and killed and maybe you know
feathered chickens arrive equally around
Skyrim for people to scoop up and take
home and chow down on so that was always
our intention but thank you very much
for for bringing that up bringing Kevin
van Lord and his chicken van nuggets
into my life next comment is from Willie
the gamer okay who says this is about
last week's show this okay yeah sexy but
not sexy uh female superheroes yes they
were they were a little different to the
normal inhabitants of Skyrim go on God I
was watching this with my grandmother
yep she now grounded me for this ha ha
what have you to say about getting
people grounded well first off I'm sorry
my apologies are tea to you I think over
your grandmother I think it was
important that she you know saw what she
saw yeah that we maybe could have put a
little warning in that maybe the body
types are going to be a little different
too heavy what you might be expecting I
can I can promise you that that was a
bit of a one-off we're not going to be
doing any more of the unique body types
anymore we're going to bring it back to
what everybody knows and
so GTA master 62 says Catwoman's uniform
was dark Brotherhood not nightingale
okay well that yeah that's just well
thank you for bringing that to my
attention at least because you're right
I do I do assume everything is
Nightingale armor because it's one of my
favorites but yes you're right that was
that Brotherhood who was the next one
from this is from Jessica s so when you
mention at the end about building a PC
will you be doing a video of it I think
I mean lots of watches I've been also
wishing to build one for quite a while
although I've not had an idea I don't
know have I don't have an idea about
what I'll be doing well well for our PC
planned feature in the future we are
going to be building a PC with the help
of Mark Walton resident PC expert and
enthusiast and we're going to be able to
put all of the best and most beautiful
graphics mods for Skyrim on that machine
and have it looking gorgeous as we
promised last week that's going to be
coming up fairly soon so I can't promise
you which week but it will be soon and
it's going to look amazing and so yes we
will film it we will put the whole thing
in video form it's gonna be gorgeous
get excited what are we voting on next
week okay so either wet and cold
holidays and then this one the thing the
thin okay the thin by insanity sorrow is
by the way is the same guy who did a mod
we've done a little while ago called the
Stanford which was this one off very
very very beautiful high res sword so
the thin is just I believe someone
described it as the little sister to
that sword very pretty very pretty and
lastly we've also got evil mastermind
armor looks terrifying frankly yeah yeah
if you wanna vote for any of those you
know the the regular link to go to what
Lucy doesn't so I'm gonna I'll handle
this this tinyurl.com forward slash
ready semi blog and I'll update the blog
post in like three weeks have updates in
so long I haven't had to come up with
any new ideas and what it what if people
wanna hound you Lucy how would they do
that hound me hound you well you can
find me on Twitter I am at Lisa James
games
because I had to have a rhyme in there
somewhere I actually like that that's
certainly better than ready
Sebby go all of the mods up for the vote
like usual have all been suggested to us
in the past if you would like to
recommend us any mods you can talk to me
already so we go and talk to Lucy at
Lucy James games or cam even though he's
not here he will be returning Lee he's
definitely not dead definitely not dead
new and he is at camp res Rob and you
can use our hashtag which is hashtag TS
skyrim as well and i guess for another
week that's hit Lucy yeah thank you so
much for sitting by my side for that
whole quest that was epic that big y'all
inquest it was insane and thank you also
for all of the mass effect mods because
they were quite excellent I will miss
riding around on tiny horses oh and
giant horses absolutely well hopefully
we'll have them back again next week do
stay tuned we'll see you here again next
time
you